six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's try
going to the eight five six
area code our next caller if if they can
hear me
we'll be from the eight five six area
code are you with us yes I am hey my
name is Jensen I think I've called into
the show before a little bit you think
you have like do you remember deaf all
right you got me I called it
I called official show before but I
really enjoy your insight on things um
my question to do was you know back in
2004 we called bush racist in 2012 hey
uh Republican policy politics of 2012
Romney was racist now we actually have
Trump do you think somebody could
actually be more like racism Trump and
try to run in like 2024 or 2028 what
have you yes and here's why and how by
the the right has done a really good job
of deflating allegations of racism and
they've done a fantastic job the same
way that there's a movement that has
sought to sort of de legitimize the
infrastructure of even saying hey XY or
z is sexist or misogynist the same
movement has succeeded or an overlapping
movement has succeeded at making a huge
portion of the electorate skeptical to
any accusation of racism and so I
believe that actually Donald Trump has
continued in that direction and will
certainly enable not necessarily someone
who is just going to come out and make
blatantly racist comments to have a shot
but to sort of marginalize and make
unimportant their views on race because
hey you know what they've got the right
position on the wall or on taxes or
whatever so that I'm pretty concerned
about that what do you think
well did people call going off on a
tangent we're laughing at the idea now
but do you think over 2020 that could be
a thing I'm sorry I didn't hear that
last question what was that last we're
laughing at the idea now but do you
think Oprah 2020 could be it
Oprah Oprah oh yeah let's see if we can
turn turn the collar up a little bit no
I actually I just saw a poll that says
that even most Democrats aren't thrilled
with the idea of Oprah
so ELISA I thought Trump was going to
lose so don't come to me for political
predictions I don't know what I'm
talking about but I Mayans think right
now is no Oprah 2020 is not going to be
a real thing okay all right thanks Dave
all right no problem appreciate the call
thank you very much